[Music]
grain never calling me about the noise
it's only two man i'm in the same
building but the floor's a few change i
ain't for the waiting now i bought a
rari and i did it just to hit a sound
guard safe really bout to lose all this
meaning now guess you love to travel
when i pull up and you leave in time say
you're married to the game
i got a flight in the morning i see what
you've been trying to do when i'm a
mission to border you think i'll never
pay attention in my mind i'm recording
i'm bout to win i'm ruining all your
ghosts and dreams out of border riding
and rubbing homies like we run the city
looking fresh and feeling like a melee
[Music]
when you see me
[Music]
making major moves rose race no top me
no one will ever stop me me against the
world i got my back against the wall oh
no i'm hellbound put them well now
hopefully around so don't make a sound
unless you make it
[Music]
that's my only thing yes i'm a born
winner 23. all my people
run it
[Music]
water
[Music]
[Music]
you